What I'm passionate about right now in healthcare is gender equity
and the work that is being done to align
leadership with an inclusive environment
and an environment where leaders really understand and are attuned
to the people they lead
regardless of that individual's background
race thinking etc.
We can't be leading from a place that doesn't understand diversity
if we are going to get to equitable health outcomes
and equitable treatment for all populations.
So I'm very passionate about how this next generation of leaders is going to
lead in a way that builds more inclusive environments
and environments more attuned to the unique needs of diverse populations.